right i wanna i wanna jump to the store
and give a shout out to mr glenn
greenwald oh yeah we have the story from
uh
well we have a lot of daily wire i'm
sorry daily mail today firebrand
journalist glenn greenwald slams msnbc
and cnn for
dangerous failure failure to investigate
issues and praises fox as the only news
outlet presenting an opposite opinion
it's crazy that we're in this era cuz i
grew up with fox news being the bad ones
that was weird and ideologically
homogeneous
but now it's it's true i mean you look
at msnbc and cnn
and if the government said it it's true
that's it fox you know tucker carlson he
brings on antifa
and the funny thing is so i i know these
activists these old hackers they posted
a photo today
of themselves with glenn greenwald and
they were like just
disparaging their young cells saying
it's not our fault we didn't change and
i'm like yo like
these people used to be fans of glenn
greenwald fans of wikileaks
now they're actively defending the fbi
and msnbc and cnn like how does this
happen
this shift so i'll tell you what
happened is people have abandoned
and i don't know maybe that never
existed but it's really gone i think
with social media in the other direction
they've abandoned the concept of
principles
everything is party it's politics it's
people but it's not principle so i'm on
the team you know either
this is my sports team or it's my
religion or whatever it is
and like no matter what it is if it's
coming from my arena i'm gonna agree
it's good and i'm not saying that you
know i don't have a set of principles
that i'm judging things against and so
i mean you see this all the time they do
the man on the street segments where you
tell somebody
a statement and you put a different name
attached and all of a sudden they don't
agree with the statement
anymore we got to get back to just
people you don't like can say
things that are interesting and make
sense and people you do like can say
things that you don't agree with or you
think that are completely
insane and it is it is every side of the
coin it is the left is the right
the easiest content you'll see it from
jimmy kimmel he goes outside and says
something like
you know donald trump said this and then
he'll get dumb people to say dumb things
and then go ha
look how dumb trump supporters are but
then you'll see the same thing for
people on the right
where they'll go out and say things like
you know barack obama said x and they'll
cheer for ah that was donald trump
or you get a lot of people who will be
like look how dumb these liberals are
and things like that
i do think the tendency tends to be on
the left however and in the mainstream
press
i think for whatever whatever reason
right now you'll find on the right with
trump supporters with conservatives
republicans
there's typically more honesty and more
attempt at good faith conversation
for example you know stephen crowder
trying to have a conversation with ethan
klein
and ethan klein's response as we see
with the mainstream on the left was to
make it a spectacle to turn it
into a bad faith troll and then the four
was in daily beast and newsweek all
laugh and hoot and yell ah we got you
crowder
the crowder was trying to have a good
faith conversation so so i don't know
what it is cause it felt like when i was
growing up the left was trying to be
good faith
but maybe that was just me being in the
matrix
it's very possible i grew up in a
non-political family i didn't know about
any of this like i completely felt
completely
tushy backwards into this when mitt
romney ran for president because they
needed somebody to explain
the auto bailouts and and all those
kinds of things and private equity was a
private equity guy
um and so they're like you're an
investment banker like you come out i
just want to be a game show host people
that's what i did i wanted to give away
pride
i still want to be a game show host but
somehow i got like dragged into this
and so like you know i didn't you know i
just basically whatever my parents said
like yeah okay but they weren't really
even
they didn't really follow any of this
stuff and then you kind of get in the
middle of it and you're like
what the heck is going on but the
craziest part about all of this is just
the guilt by association
and the cancel culture whether you do it
yourself or whether it's you know you've
got somebody on the back of your book
that some corporation doesn't like
and now they're not buying your books
anymore
couple days before book launch not that
this happened
it didn't happen did it did it happen so
this this is the
breaking news you could be the first
people to hear about this
um and this is so disappointing because
it's like one person who's not even
in the organization so i'm not going to
name the organization because i like the
organization it's a big
big old company who wanted to have me
come out and give a speech
and instead of charging my speaking fee
i said well if you buy
the equivalent amount of the books then
you can give everybody a book and you
know well
win-win for everyone oh this is great
and they're talking publicism we're
working out the details
well one outside pr consultant looked at
the six
different names on the back of the book
that represent
all different viewpoints because that's
a great thing about small business it
brings people together
and they didn't like one of the names
and they
thought that that tainted me and blew
up the entire thing and i'm like how is
it the fact that
i'm building bridges and bringing
together different viewpoints a
bad thing you would think that's exactly
what we need
at this point in time about a topic that
again like i don't even even talk about
it you can talk about whatever you want
you're buying my books like you're
i'm on your clock i could talk about
anything i'll talk about football hockey
i don't really care
so they could have done anything or they
could have
but like i'm now canceled and my book
orders are literally
cancelled because they pulled out one of
the six names one person
outside pr person didn't want that
association
if you knew that that name would have
had would have resulted in this
circumstance would you remove it nope
because i am in the fortunate position
where i can make
those decisions and i've told people
before like i'm getting the vans on the
book anyway like i don't care if it
sells one copy or whatever i'm not doing
this
for financial needs i'm doing this
because it's a really important message
that everybody needs to hear they need
to just to
spread and also if this book doesn't do
well
nobody's going to do anything about
small business in the media again
because i don't know if you guys know
this
probably not because this is my domain
but like
any media that has to do with small
business has all been pulled away there
used to be tv shows
they pulled them up the air if you try
to get a segment on a major show
you can't they have completely taken
away so this is the
entry to for people to say we care about
small business
and you know but they're trying to take
that away well let's think about that
for a second um i think you did the
right i think
that was the right thing if if it were
me i would not remove the name of any
comment or endorsement simply because
someone would threaten to cancel me so
i think you you're saying the right
thing i agree with you but there's also
the argument that
couldn't you have reached more ears by
you
canceling one of those endorsements
yeah it's i mean it goes back to
principle it's just not the way that i
roll i'm hoping that i can can find a
different way let me tell you a story
about my last book
because i think this will give you this
will give you a little sense of who i am
so when i wrote my last book the
entrepreneur equation
my publisher at the time had the idea of
putting a picture of me on the book
cover
and if you've seen the book cover it's
me and pink heels in front of a
chalkboard doing a little like sexy
teacher kind of thing
or whatever they conceptualized it and
back in the day there were actually
bookstores
and one of the big bookstores one of the
buyers told my publisher
you know she's a little too attractive
to be taken seriously as a business
author
so we kind of think you should either
pull her off the cover of the book
or you know maybe like ugly her up a
little bit
and so they came back to me with this
feedback and they said you know
by the way my last poster was very very
collaborative they were great and they
said
it's your book but these guys are really
important so like what do you want to do
i said well not only am i going to do
this but i'm going to do the biggest
blank blank to them of all time and for
those of you who know i have my own
fashion doll slash action figure
that was made as a premium to match what
i look like on the book cover and so for
every
book that was sent out the action figure
was sent with it and i just kind of
doubled down on that and said that was
the thing
so that's kind of how i approach it but
again i have the ability
to do that when when somebody does care
about like that book sale is going to
put food on the table they don't have
the flexibility to make the same choices
that i do and so i'm cognizant which is
why i
care about these topics because not
everybody can do that
it's a big challenge yeah knowing that
there's this
system in place that is is uh
unreasonable
and that's that this story is kind of
nuts like
without saying with the person is it is
a mainstream normal person
it is totally crazy that a company would
be like i don't know about that guy
i actually had um right i mean it's not
like i've got like
like manson on the cover like like oh
you should really i mean
yeah these are all these are all
well-known people you may not agree with
them
but yeah i actually had the daily beast
wrote an article about the uh
john mcafee thing and i i tweeted uh
bowl effing ish in response to the story
and i linked john mcafee saying i would
never take my own life
and so they incorporate that into the
story which i don't care they called me
a conspiracy theorist it's like okay
if i was making i i didn't make an
assertion about what happened i just
said bs like i don't believe the story
not believing a story is not asserting a
conspiracy but they called me alt-right
it's that i was all right and i'm like
they just make it up i get called out
right for this
too yeah literally because i had one
person they didn't like on the book
which is like hilarious because like i'm
an independent like jewish woman like
my old friend it's because they know
it'll taint
in in the future someone will look back
now i i was fortunate enough look i
i i go i go through things in the very
normal way i don't go on twitter and
start screaming like this is ridiculous
quiet email requesting a retraction and
a correction
and they immediately responded with an
apology and took it out
i'm lucky that happened good for you
because a lot of there was
there was one period where they there
was you know they lie about people all
day and night
and i think the scary thing is that for
you mentioned the little guy
doesn't have the opportunity to make
these these choices
what are you supposed to do when you're
going up against a multi-million dollar
corporations lied about
you and there's not much you can do so i
look at it this way as well
um i was flying on american airlines
once and
our flight got delayed because of a
major storm it was in i think it was in
dallas
and so i went i i
went on twitter and you know tweeted i'm
like hey is there any update on this i
couldn't get through the phone line
and the next thing i know they're like
mr pool we're going to take care of you
and make sure everything is perfect
step to the line right now and let them
know when i walk with the line i look to
my right
huge line hundreds of people waiting and
i'm like it's kind of screwed up
they because they don't fear the regular
person who can't do anything about their
circumstances but they're worried i
could tweet and cause them problems
i don't like that idea i don't like
tweeting at companies but sometimes it's
the only way to get them to react well
it's
interesting so tying it back into what
happened you know with covin and small
business and ppp
you know this is exactly the where the
structure of ppp failed so badly
is that they put you know these
parameters where you could have
millions and millions of dollars in
assets and revenue and you could still
you know go in and apply for these ppp
comp or ppp loans
so if you're a bank and you've got like
the guy who's got millions of dollars
and you've been doing business with
them and then you've got like this pizza
shop that's like struggling to make it
like whose loan are you going to fulfill
first of course you're going to fulfill
your good customer
it shouldn't they've never should never
been put in that position in the first
place and so that goes back to a flaw in
the structure it's hard
to fault the person who has the loyal
relationship whose business is
also going to depend on it but why was
it structured that way to begin with and
i think those are the questions we need
to continue to ask
we need smart contracts to dole out
these things like um this is
part of the great thing about
cryptocurrency is there's no middleman
to decide where what's going to happen
or where it's going to go you have the
parameters and
it fits and there it is on in on the
blockchain out in the open
which is why is it why it's a threat to
them i have some i'm optimistic
you know a couple days ago we were
talking to bannon he was saying
we're winning once these these moms see
what hap what happens to their kids or
these schools they're teaching on august
15th it's going to be it's going to be
crazy and and that was a really really
good point i'm also confident because of
the things we're doing over at
timcast.com and the tremendous
support we have from all of you who are
members you guys are amazing
we're able to hire journalists we're
expanding like crazy things are going
better than ever
we're trying really hard to move away
from youtube because that was putting
our all our eggs in one basket it's very
very dangerous
we're trying to build something
substantive and so i'm confident that
not only are we going to succeed with
the support of our paying members
we're finding new ways to generate
revenue new ways to
support real news and fact check and all
of that
makes me optimistic and there's another
thing that makes me really optimistic is
seeing stories like this one
brian stelter's revised anti-trump
diatribe hoax
tanks with less than 2 000 copies sold
in its first week
despite massive book tour and launch
party as
ratings for his cnn show dropped to its
lowest of the year
seeing this happen he sold 1 738 copies
in his first week
wow that's very very very few books so
here's the thing is that i guess
when people hate watch a show they don't
hate buy a book i mean because i mean
that that's i mean
and again i don't like to pick on
people's livelihoods but i do feel
like based on everything i've seen there
are a lot of people who
watch the show that most of the
commentary isn't oh i'm enjoying this
thing it's literally hate watching it
seems like that's the big part of his
audience which i think is hard to
translate
at the same time i'm not going to make
fun of that number of book sales because
you know i've got a book that's coming
out i've got big corporate media
who doesn't want to cover it i've got
big corporations who are canceling me
so i might do worse than brian's delter
sure sure but this is this is a guy who
goes on tv and he tells people not to
watch other shows
he's got this massive cnn platform
that's ratings are in decline
and now he can't sell his book i mean
this is a guy who was getting over a
million viewers
now he's getting around seven eight
hundred thousand it's going down hey
that's still a lot of viewers
weighs more than i'm getting but you see
that decline at the same time
it it look i'm not trying to
there is a bit of i guess spite in like
haha watching someone
fail and everything like that but i
genuinely think what he does is is
dangerous what cnn does
is bad they lie they manipulate they're
part of the problem
and they represent the decentralized
media i'm gonna give a plug to you right
now centralized media
the centralized media and you are the
decentralization and so i mean if you're
enjoying this
you should be supporting tim and i'm
going to support you because i believe
in this
because decentralization is critical and
this is the american dream and
capitalism is about putting your dollars
where
your belief system is you you can't go
out and say you know
alexa why does jeff bezos have so much
money
could you order me some doritos and tell
me the sales on prime days and then go
like well what you know what's going on
she's gonna be like i can't talk about
that okay okay she we actually have one
and you call her but she didn't respond
you can ask her all sorts of questions
about jeff she's like okay i'm not gonna
talk
but that's what i'm saying so you so so
support the things that you believe
in and support these small companies and
support small business and support small
business advocacy
that's how you make a dent and and don't
support don't don't hate watch
things you don't like because it's
giving them dollars i mean i know
it's fun and whatever but like don't do
it support the things like let's make it
a positive instead of a negative
and go out and support because you are
the american dream you're building
that you're helping other people with
them
getting more jobs and creating something
that's important and we need more of
that
and people should should buy your book
the war on small business by carol roth
why
amazon is one of the most powerful ways
that decentralized media has been able
to get a foothold and challenge the
establishment
i mentioned this the other day with
michael nol's book speechless definitely
you should buy speechless you should buy
unmasked by andy now jackpot's book um
antique that's the internet
yeah oh yeah because when people go to
amazon and michael malus's book the
anarchist
handbook create space i believe is where
it is you can you can publish your own
books
you go on amazon and you'll see the top
charts and it's a bunch of
anti-establishment thinkers it's people
challenging conventional wisdom with
with interesting ideas
and they don't all agree with each other
but it's it's a way to break through
when the establishment
the mainstream when cnn when they don't
give the time of day when brian selter
comes on tv and says don't watch the
spin come to us
when was it tapper who said you can't
read wikileaks emails only we are it's
illegal only we can read it
you can now find the honest and
dissenting voices because
amazon has to put them in the ranking
same as everybody else
granted they do ban books which is
another scary component of this but so
long as we have an opportunity
if everybody buys your book we can get
this top 10 list which is going to
include a bunch of people of varying
political ideologies
and that will what will happen is a
regular person will be browsing amazon
where they see number one they see carol
roth number
number number one they say michael
knowles or andy no or people like ben
shapiro or dave rubin
and now they're going to get an idea
they normally wouldn't have got from
cnn so this is so interesting so this is
a good um sort of capitalism debate
because i had been directing people to
bookshop.org
because i don't know if you're familiar
with bookshop.org but what it does
is it fulfills books from local small
business book sellers
so you get a not only support small
business advocacy in terms of the book
that you're buying and learning these
concepts and spreading the concepts but
you actually get it
put a couple dollars towards the small
business but it's an interesting point
because at the same time if it doesn't
chart well
on amazon then the people outside the
ones who are buying it here also
don't get so i need you to buy two books
could you buy one on amazon
and buy one on bookshop give it to a
friend no but seriously um
but it is an interesting sort of
question is do you want to
like do you to take down and get some
foothold
do you need to chart on the big place
and you know
change minds or do we support the small
guys
and win in that direction and maybe
they're not mutually exclusive no i
don't think they are i think you should
support both
yeah i want to rub cnn's nose in it a
little bit cause i got this
okay okay this is important guys i need
to beat brian stelter
so even if you don't care about this
book i can't sell
fewer copies than he does well no no i'm
going to bring up a costa
rican so this is a story from two years
ago president donald trump cnn's jim
acosta spar over journalist book sales
granted from 2019
it's still kind of funny so trump is
talking and then they say
um he was asked about uh muhammad bin
salman
and then trump flips the script saying i
don't really care about offending people
i sort of thought you know that flips
the script and says by the way
congratulate to jim acosta by the way by
the way congratulations i understand
your book is it doing well
it's doing very well mr president acosta
said trump seemed astonished
really i'll get you an autographed copy
acosta offered
it's from deadline by the way not from
fox news they say
acosta's book isn't doing that well it's
in the 1300s on amazon
he was previously zinged on the lagging
sales by fox news sean hannity who
called the book a disaster and an
epic fail so yes like you said it's
people watch these shows because they
hate trump or they hate the right
not because they like acosta's reporting
not because they like brian stelter
so when the name pops up that says
seltzer they say i don't care
if the if the book was why trump is bad
by guy who hates trump
they might actually buy that book yeah
well and my only again my issue
on principle and not personage is that
he's got a show called reliable sources
that does not have reliable sources
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this
channel youtube.com tim cast irl
monday through friday at 8pm where you
can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you